So we have come across this high level architecture for deliberation earlier.
Today we will talk about a specific cognitive architecture for deliberation.
This architecture is called SOAR. I should mention that SOAR not only
covers deliberation, SOAR can also cover certain aspects of reaction, and some
aspects of meta cognition. But we are going to focus mostly on the deliberation
component and so on. SOAR was initiated by Allen Neville, John Lear, and
Paul Rosenbloom. And John Lear and Paul Rosenbloom have been working on it for
the last 30 years or so. The highest level consists of a long term memory and
a working memory. The [INAUDIBLE] itself contains different kinds of knowledge.
In particular SOAR talks about three kinds of knowledge. Procedural, semantic,
and episodic. Episodic knowledge has to do with events.
Specific instances of events, like, what did you have for dinner yesterday.
Semantic knowledge has to do with generalizations in the form of concepts and
models of the world. For example, your concept of a human being, or
your model of how a plane flies in the air.
Procedural has to do with how to do certain things. So as an example, how do you
pour water from a jug into a tumbler. Notice that this makes an architecture.
There are different components that are interacting with each other.
This arrangement of components will afford certain processes of reasoning and
learning. That's exactly the kind of processes of reasoning and
learning that we'll look at next.